all right thank you all so much for all
of your talks today they've been so
informative and we've had some some
really great feedback and some great
great questions so some of them that
there's kind of some general questions
that perhaps anyone on the panel might
be able to answer might someone be able
to tell us a little bit about the mean
age of first attempts when do we start
seeing suicidal behavior in individuals
and are there any subgroups of of
individuals we have one specific
question about transgender individuals
that we might want to be monitoring and
as young adults or as teenagers in terms
of age group suicidal behavior below the
age of 14 is rare it does happen there's
a small number in the age range of 10 to
14 it starts to increase from 15 onward
and there's a kind of a large cohort in
the age range of young adults 21 to 24
where you see an increase
so the second part of that question
actually in terms of transgender
individuals actually practice and they
do have a higher risk for suicide as a
another potential you know broadly
speaking risk factor and then we might
think that there might be very different
underlying mechanisms or reasons for
that then some of the other diagnoses
that we talked about today
a trick question so we actually get
quite a few questions about when do you
start administering scale and you start
doing the assessment and I just want to
mention one study that came out
literally just just came out and it
really looks at suicidal ideation and
preschoolers and kindergarteners this is
a very robust research program and it
really looks at continuity of non
behavior but suicidal ideation and how
to assess and so in terms of the
frequency of behaviors Barbara I think
answered that question there's a couple
of really good articles to that effect
including mad knocks and wrong kessler's
piece documenting the really low
incidence but in terms of the early
early signs if you will of suicidal or
phenomena then we certainly have
evidence that suicidal seems do begin
emerging in very early childhood and
unfortunately continue thank you dr.
Stanley we had a question asking whether
you could comment on safety plan
planning for inpatients especially
during the high-risk period when a
patient is about to be discharged the
community
so the the only time that safety
planning shouldn't be done with suicidal
people is when they are in the midst of
an emergency themselves so if they need
immediate rescue like for example crisis
hotlines do safety planning with people
but if on the crisis hotline it seems
like the person the crisis is not going
to de-escalate then you don't do with
safety plan I can say that safety plans
are being done on inpatient units in
jails in emergency departments in an
outpatient setting so I think it's a
it's appropriate to do in all of those
settings and it's a good thing to give
to people who come in for a suicidal
crisis right now we're we have started
testing out we're just doing a small
feasibility study looking at an
inpatient group treatment for suicidal
patients that's like a four session
thing each session is a standalone
session and one of those sessions is
doing safety planning terrific terrific
another theme that's really come up in
the question is that is that is a theme
that was across talks today about
interpersonal triggers of suicide
attempts so that came up again and again
in the discussion and some of the
audience had questions about what
specifically can we be doing with
clients to handle help them handle their
potential interpersonal triggers and
related to that a second question is is
our interpersonal triggers more an issue
of emotion regulation distress tolerance
or something else altogether
well you know I think in terms of what
we can be doing I you know in thinking
about how our patients view themselves
and view other people how they think
about what other people are thinking
that was what I was thinking my one of
my slides I talked about mentalization
based interventions and this idea of
helping them to better understand the
perspective of others how others might
be interacting with them in ways that
will then help them to kind of manage
some of the negative effect that comes
with those negative or perceived
negative interpersonal experiences so I
think helping with kind of stability and
sense of self and stability in terms of
how they're viewing other people can
really help and for me I see that a lot
with the interpersonal effectiveness
modules as I said but I also think
mindfulness of being present I think
right you know emotion regulation of
helping with regulating negative effect
in these interpersonal encounters will
be very helpful and always is the first
line that distress tolerance skills and
in terms of immediately being maybe
distracting or removing from an
interpersonal situation that could be
really high intense and in effect so
that the last half of that question is
really very important to question about
what causes what causes what and a lot
of us who do research in this area are
thinking about that and and we really
don't have the answer I mean that's like
the $50,000 50 million dollar question
about is it the emotion regulation that
causes the interpersonal dysfunction or
vice versa we actually really don't know
the the thing I will say about
interpersonal triggers is number one for
people who make suicide attempts there
there is always a trigger that we can
identify and so for people with BPD it's
more on the interpersonal than the
interpersonal so in a certain way I kind
of don't make that much of that but on
the other hand I tried to understand the
interpersonal dysfunction is actually
really complicated because so I'll give
you an example
Eric Furtick who is a young investigator
working with me it did fMRI study where
he looked at rejection of rejection
paradigm and in the scanner and what he
found is that people who have borderline
personality disorder take each rejection
in the same kind of way as though it's
like so a rejection in the context of a
lot of acceptance is experiences just as
much rejection as rejection rejection
rejection as opposed to people who don't
have borderline personality disorder who
they they acknowledge the rejection but
it but it is only bad when it's in the
context of a lot of rejection and so not
to get deep into this study but in other
words it's like it's not something that
is incredibly simple it's a complex
phenomenon to understand what the
interpersonal dysfunction is in
borderline personality disorder and what
the underlying neurobiology of it is
great another set of questions really
focus on the idea of whether we've been
talking a lot today about predicting
suicidality whether we're very poor
it-it-it right now but are there always
triggers of suicidality or is there
actually suicide attempts with
absolutely no triggers with absolutely
no predictors what does the panel think
of that first premise
a cough drop but I think that in general
can't speak up yeah
our clients would probably come in and
report many different experiences with
suicide behaviors and to say
unilaterally that it never happened I
don't know I think that we try to avoid
unilateral statements but again when you
break down and very carefully like in
behavioral change analysis these suicide
attempts often we can help increase
understanding and insight into
potentially some of the things that
might contribute to a suicide attempt
and I would say probably more often than
not there is something even if it's
something that is might be seen as
relatively small but that there can be
something that happened prior to or
leading up to a suicide attempt maybe
others would disagree on the panel
you know one comment as a family member
on that and that is that often times
experienced
[Music]
that good that we couldn't pin down a
specific event that preceded the attempt
so but there always was it just took
time to find out what it was it are in
in our case with our son
there there often was a trigger there
was an event there was a thought process
that he eventually over time could
identify but not in the short term
perhaps not in that first couple of
sessions with the clinician after the
attempt so one thing I would say about
triggers is the the trigger is just the
last thing that happens prior to the to
the attempt and that there are many
other things that that kind of lead up
to that that attempt and so you could in
the the reason I I guess I was saying
that we we shouldn't put that much stock
in individual triggers is because a lot
of times you can have the same trigger
and nothing will happen and so it just
is kind of like that that cascade of
things that then and then you identify
that okay that was what happened just
before and so we call it the trigger but
it's like a whole bunch of things that
are the triggering events
you got to add to me it's also important
to re frame that question in a couple of
different ways one instance on one
scenario when that question comes up is
could I have foreseen this happening and
as a clinician as a parent the desire to
predict usually is associated with could
I have foreseen and the answer to that
question most of the time a lot of the
time is now and the other way to look at
the question is there an explanation is
there a cause and this is you know other
speakers have already addressed and
there are explanations this is
explainable so it also sounds like from
the talks today that you might say that
when we initially ask the questions
there seems like they don't have
suicidal ideation beforehand or before
the attempt or they don't identify the
triggers but as we ask more structured
clinical interviews of suicide risk that
we might be able to ascertain more
clarity in that thought process in the
nuances of what is really leading up to
it and that may be something interrupted
it and so they deny that as a suicide
attempt but it really might might be so
there's both a assessment issue and then
also a clinical issue to that question
would you guys agree yeah okay
so another question really focused on
how in with regards to assessment of a
suicide attempt and framing and
understanding of it how often do you a
clue include family in both the
knowledge and assessment of suicidal
ideation for adults not just adolescents
again it just takes a second one that's
a really good question so it's
complicated because that very much
because when you're dealing with an
adult as your patient it depends on what
the patient's wishes and desires are if
the patient doesn't want the family
included they're not included they can't
be included but one of the things that I
in my work there are often individuals
who are adults but who are really kind
of cared for still by their parents and
so one of the things that I make clear
to the family members and the patient is
that it is fine for family members to
communicate anything they want to be
either by phone or by email and even if
my patient doesn't want me to talk with
them I'm I can receive information and
I'm happy to receive information and my
patients know that that's my I would
never say to a family member you cannot
tell me that you know this happened over
the weekend so so that becomes a way to
actually learn about the important
clinical information that the patient
may not be sharing with me if the
patient is willing and wants this where
I what I often will do is include the
family member in the development and
sharing of the safety plan with them
because especially because they are on
usually it's if it's a spouse they're on
the safety plan and so it's important to
know for the the patient to know will
are you comfortable talking with this
person and letting the person know
they're on your safety plan and so it's
it's a good way to kind of bring the
person here
thank you all right another question
focuses on how some individuals when
they are in a crisis moment maybe before
a suicide attempt or when they're
planning they might have their memory
processes impaired where they report
that they weren't able to remember
details of it or they also report they
weren't able to remember coping skills
in the moment what what might you
recommend for clients who report that
both first assessment and planning
intervention well again I think that
they're having abnormalities and
attempters in the hippocampus which
involve is involved in memory processes
and while we may not completely
understand how memory processes get
disrupted it is possible that there is
some retrieval difficulties in those
moments and then I think the first thing
that comes to mind again when we're
thinking about different strategies is
some distress tolerance to just wait
wait for a little bit to have them have
crisis survival strategies already
planned out maybe during a sort of a
crisis plan that can be part of it as
well is this is what you try first when
you can't remember anything else because
then that buys time for the emotional
responding in the brain to start to
subside for some of these other brain
circuitry to come back sort of online to
enable them to retrieve what they know
to do and then over time hopefully it
becomes more routine and more habit so
that there's less difficulty in
retrieving what we're supposed to do but
you might be earlier on in treatment -
there can be settling more difficulties
as we're learning new techniques that
have been newly sort of formed as
memories as it were
well don't people don't forget what
happened prior to a suicide attempt
unless they were under the influence and
then of course they're they're not going
to remember but when you sit down with
somebody and you and the experience of I
don't nothing happened or I don't
remember nothing one of the things that
I say is like basically kind of like
humor me let's just try to we don't have
to say this led to that led to that
we're just we'll just do a chronology of
events a timeline and by doing a
timeline you're not saying this led to
this but you're getting the timeline and
and then you can see what led what is
happening along the timeline so it's a
very different kind of like it's a
figure-ground kind of thing and it makes
it easier for people to trace backwards
um but I people don't people do remember
unless they're intoxicated all right
well thank you very much speakers panel
where we're going to wrap it up just a
little bit late today but we greatly
appreciate all of your comments and your
suggestions I also want to thank down in
front today there have been two
individuals who've been working very
hard Sandra Lee and Anita Benjamin who
have been translating sign language
translators all day they have had a very
long day and I just want to give them a
hand
thank you thank you so much
[Music]